we begin with some very good news an
exciting milestone
in the fight against the coronavirus
today half of
all adults in america are fully
vaccinated more than 60 percent
of the adults in the u.s have had at
least one shot
and there's also been major progress in
vaccinating kids
studies show the pfizer and moderna
vaccines are safe
and 100 percent effective in kids as
young as 12.
but some parents are still nervous about
the shot
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in los angeles where officials
just launched a program to vaccinate
kids at school
david how's it going so far
slow i got to be honest when we came to
this school in downtown los angeles
yesterday there were only
two kids in line and the organizers were
kind of disappointed
by the end of the day they had
vaccinated i'd say about 230 people
now here at lausd the school system
they're planning to do over 13 days
vaccination clinics at 250 schools and
as you said
it's not just enough to get the kid to
say i want the vaccine you got to get
mom and dad to approve
and that's not always easy
that's it all right do you feel that at
all no see
it is back to school for dr jerry
abraham that's your dad
now that kids ages 12 and up are
eligible for the vaccine
dr abraham has partnered with the la
school district to get students the shot
but his latest vaccination campaign has
a unique challenge
we've definitely had to talk had very
difficult conversations with moms and
dads about why their kids
should be vaccinated we hear the
microchipping we hear that
you're going to grow a tail become a
mutant it's going to affect your
reproductive organs i mean just none of
those things are
true so to help combat that
misinformation
dr abraham helped to launch a canvassing
effort called get out the shot
they go door to door across various
communities to educate people
and get them registered for the vaccine
now this effort is a far cry from the
early days when the vaccine was first
available
that's when dr abraham's south la clinic
called kedran health
was overwhelmed with vaccine demand
that was the easy part now you've got
students who really
want it because it can mean getting to
join the basketball team
or getting to go to clippers game or to
the movies
but now your parents are saying we don't
have enough information
it is really heartbreaking to see
someone who wants to get vaccinated and
then they're not able to because their
family doesn't want them to
he told us about one of those young
people and we went to meet him
seventeen-year-old jovani balthazar he's
helped to canvas for dr
abraham with get out the shot he even
signed up some of his peers
but when it came time to get the vaccine
jovani's mother said
no and not even dr abraham could
convince her
otherwise she was kind of afraid of me
getting the vaccine
um because of like the side effects how
long did it take to convince your mom
to allow you to get it well it took a
couple of weeks like two weeks we talked
to my doctor about this and got a green
light from my doctor so now my mom's in
mom's in yes sir black brown yellow or
white
your vaccine your choice but you have
questions and everyone
has the right to have their questions
answered we believe it is in your
child's best interest in our community's
best interest that everyone over
12 who has no medical contraindications
gets vaccinated that is what we know
right now kids are getting the pfizer
vaccine but moderna is about to get
added to the mix modern is going to ask
for emergency use authorization
very soon according to modernity its
adolescent trials have shown that the
vaccine
is 100 effective in kids ages 12 to 17.
gail all right 100 effective normally a
very good thing thank you very much
david